OPPORTUNITY TO MEASURE
THEMSELVES.
PLAYING AGAINST A GOOD
EXCITING GAME AS THE HABS
CONTROL.
SUZUKI, RIGHT SHOT
FACE-OFF.
QUICK LITTLE OUT,SUZUKI.ON'T WO
WE'RE STILL GOING TO PLAY.
AND PETRY PINCH UP
>> Bryan::
>> Bryan: MARCHMENT, ON THE PUCK
FOR FLORIDA, TRYING T LIKE HE'ST
IN. ALWAYS GOOD TO GET YOUR
SUZUKI, TO THE LINE.
THAT SHOT ROMANOV, KNOCKED
IN COMESWAY.
WATCH MARCHMENT TAKE  ATTEMPT
AWAY, GETS
TO THE  ALL THE WAY
AROUND.
MASON MARCHMENT THE RECIPIENT OF
THAT.
YEAH, HE JUST ABSOLUTELY JUST
>> Dave: VERY LATE BLOOMER, IN
TORONTO'S ORGANIZATION, THEY LE!
BACK IN FRONT, BARKOV LOOKING
FOR THE PUCK.
QUICK SHOT, >> Dave: YOUNG GOAL
I'LL TAKE A BREATH.
I'M TIRED JUST WATCHING THE P
PEZZETTA.
TRYING TO FEED REM PITLICK.
HOFFMAN TRIES IT  SPENCER
KNIGHT'S VISION RIGHT THERE.
AND THEN AS HE SLIDES ACROSS AL
TRAFFIC MAKES THE STOP.
HUBERDEAU SPINS UCLOSE.
THAT'S CLOSE. YOUR
THIRD LINE.
>> Bryan: HERE'STHINK JEFF PETR
STEVE SHUTT, COLE  PANTHERS.
HE CERTAINLY HLINE.
TRYING TO DROP TO CAUFIELD.
>> Bryan: WELCOME BACK TO THEWAY
FROM THER LOST HIS STICK.
UP COMES DVORAK, ALLEN OUT
FRONT, BEATS SAM BENNETT TO THE